bonjour à tous on démarre ce nouveau
numéro au coeur de l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
il y ait le loisir ce sont 600 hectares
d'espacés naturels un cadre vraiment
parfait pour pratiquer la course à pied
d'ailleurs il faut savoir que de
nombreux travailleurs viennent tous les
midis pour parcourir les plus de huit
kilomètres de sentiers qui bordent
l'étang de saint quentin en yvelines la
clé juste derrière moi c'est le plus
grand plan d'eau de l'île de france et
ce n'est pas le seul lieu dans
l'agglomération qui est vraiment idéal
pour pratiquer la course à pied au
quotidien y en a plein d'autres je
voulais faire découvrir dans ce numéro
saint quentin un territoire qui courent
c'est parti
et
les principaux avantages de saint
quentin en yvelines pour la pratique de
la course à pied sont incontestablement
la grande diversité des parcours et la
variété des paysages par exemple à
plaisir où je me trouve
vous pouvez commencer votre séance par
le parc du château
ensuite un petit passage par la ville
est très vite vous vous retrouvez en
pleine forêt les forêts parcs et espaces
naturels occupent près des deux tiers du
territoire un terrain de jeu optimal
pour permettre aux saint quentinois de
se mettre à la course à pied dans les
meilleures conditions c'est un vecteur
de bien-être c'est un facteur de forme
physique
c'est un vecteur également
intellectuelle parce que je pense que
l'effort physique permet ensuite
d'obtenir une forme globale beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus agréable et permet
d'affronter aussi les épreuves de la vie
quotidienne beaucoup plus sereinement
force est de constater que la course à
pied a le vent en poupe pour répondre
aux attentes de tous les mordus du
bitume et de la terre battue
quatorze courses hors stades sont
organisées tous les ans à saint quentin
en yvelines et à chaque fois elles font
le plein de participants
on
si la course vie sur le territoire c'est
aussi grâce aux associations comme
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines une structure intercommunale
né à la fin des années 90 du
rassemblement de plusieurs clubs
en fait on s'est rencontrés pour créer à
l'époque le cross de 50 terme sur la
base de loisirs et l'idée c'était de
mutualiser les moyens ni même parce que
chacun de son côté même l'isiq était
déjà une structure assez importantes ne
se sentait pas capable en termes de
bénévolat de 2
deux villes de matériel enfin tout ce
que vous pouvez imaginer de d'organiser
tout seul depuis cette époque l'entente
athlétique a largement transformé
l'essai aujourd'hui elle compte plus de
800 adhérents qui s'entraîne au sein
d'écoles répartis sur six communes de
saint quentin en yvelines
plusieurs athlètes de haut niveau ont
fait leurs armes dans ces écoles
la preuve s'il en fallait que la
mutualisation des moyens
ça fonctionne une démarche d'ailleurs
encouragé par la communauté
d'agglomération
le but d'une intercommunalité c'est de
mettre les différents moyens en commun
pour permettre de mutualiser et
permettre de faire autant de choses avec
moins de moyens notamment avec les
contraintes budgétaires actuelles et
donc nous avons un intérêt communautaire
vraiment à faire vivre ce type de
l'association et ce type de club dans
les prochaines années l'entente
athlétique espère bien être rejointes
par d'autres communes de l'agglomération
des dialogues sont actuellement en cours
dans ce sens se dire qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire de mieux avec ce qui
existe en fait parce que le but de la
mutualisation c'est pas d'espérer avoir
plus sage pour ça marche
oui effectivement nous nos niveaux c'est
vrai qu'on a eu plus mais la vraie
question c'est on a eu plus lorsqu'on a
mis un projet en place et qu'on a prouvé
que ça pouvait apporter à une grande
majorité de gens des moyens
supplémentaires pour pratiquer est ce
encore une fois quel que soit le niveau
de pratique être
parmi les spots vraiment incontournable
pour pratiquer la course à pied à saint
quentin en yvelines il y a évidemment
les étangs de la minière alors ils ont
été créé au xviie siècle par colbert
pour alimenter le parc du château de
versailles et aujourd'hui ils font le
bonheur de tous des familles des
ornithologues des pêcheurs et évidemment
des coureurs puisque c'est le thème du
jour alors là il est midi et demi nous
sommes en pleine semaine et vous allez
voir sa salle ça court de partout la ce
a déjà un petit peu commencé ce sont des
sportifs qui viennent principalement des
entreprises alentour et court en solo ou
bien en groupe
c'est le cas par exemple de l'asm
bouygues que j'ai rencontré pour vous
les sections triathlon et course à pied
de l'asm bouygues regroupe près d'une
centaine de salariés fondu de sport qui
s'entraînent toutes les semaines avec
l'athlète de haut niveau carmen oliveras
pour cette coach au tempérament bien
trempé courir entre collègues permet de
faire tomber les barrières et renforce
la cohésion de groupe
une fois on est tous habillés en survêt
basket on est tous ensemble bien au ckc
ans va être dur pour tout le monde
souffre ensemble et je pense que tout ça
permet à certains textes dans le milieu
entreprises n'osais pas se parler mais
je pense que là du coup y'a que les
échanges qu'ils doivent s'effectuer à
mon avis dans le milieu du sport les
coureurs s'entraînent de septembre à
juin
et ce quelle que soit la saison ça nous
permet de faire un break et entre midi
et deux de pouvoir repartir l'après midi
plus fringants encore plus motivé avec
beaucoup de dynamisme
parce que le fait de devoir faire une
journée continue et faire un bon repas à
midi ça nous convient pas donc on
préfère couper la journée comme ça avec
un moment de sport parfois on a une
réunion qui se colle au dernier moment
donc on est bloqué on est obligé de
rester en réunion et puis quand on a le
temps on se sauve un petit peu plus tard
dont on rate l'on rate le train mais bon
on arrive quand même à faire 20 minutes
30 minutes de sport et c'est toujours ça
de pris
le turnover dans l'équipe est d'environ
25 % d'une année sur l'autre
l'effectif lui reste stable en grande
partie grâce à l'émulation entre
collègues il ya besoin pour supporter
les charges de travail de plus en plus
importante d'avoir un équilibre à côté
et de se montrer qu'on n'est pas tout
seul il suffit d'avoir deux ou trois
collègues un peu moteur qui derrière
vont en parler autour d'eux et ces gens
vont venir petit à petit vous y prendre
goût et après on se dit ah bon on n'est
peut-être pas forcément tous du même
niveau mais c'est pas grave puisque on
se sert de l'émulation entre nous pour
progresser au niveau en r et puis après
on a plaisir à se retrouver
les membres des sections triathlon et
course à pied de l'asm bric se
retrouvent régulièrement pour des
sorties le week end ou des cross inter
entreprises au cours desquelles ils ont
réalisé dernièrement d'excellentes
performances
courir à saint quentin en yvelines c'est
vraiment l'occasion de prendre
pleinement conscience de la richesse du
territoire en matière d' espaces
naturels après l'hymne de loisirs et les
étangs de la minière je me trouve
actuellement dans le bois de maurepas
plus précisément au bord du bassin de la
courance un site qui comprend notamment
l'un des nombreux parcours de santé de
l'agglomération
c'est vraiment un endroit idéal pour
ceux qui ont envie de se lancer dont la
pratique de la course à pied est
justement en parlant de débutant je vous
propose est là la rencontre de benoît
rapicault un coach sportif qui va nous
donner quelques conseils
il y a de cela quelques mois ses
coureurs étaient pour la plupart de
grands débutants dans une dizaine de
jours ils courront un peu plus de 21 km
à paris et pour en arriver là ils ont dû
travailler dur et franchir des étapes la
progressivité est en effet la clé pour
démarrer la course à pied
pour les gens qui sont vraiment novice
conques ont pas fait de sport depuis
depuis longtemps il faut alterner marche
course à pied ont fait monter le coeur
ont fait redescendre ont fait monter on
fera descendre pour que le corps
s'habitue progressivement à cet effort
et puis progressivement on va augmenter
le temps de course et a éliminé le temps
de marche
l'idéal c'est rouvert au moins deux fois
par semaine au bout de quinze jours
trois semaines on doit arriver à couvrir
30 minutes
en continu si on ne leur en font c'est
honteux on a bien fait ces deux séances
de manière attention même un athlète
comme benoît rapicault le reconnaît
courir pour courir n'est pas toujours
drôle
un conseil pour vous motiver fixez vous
un objectif comme par exemple une
épreuve
quand on a un objectif tout de suite on
s'astreint à être régulier à
l'entraînement si on n'a pas atteint cet
objectif final est bien on a du mal
à se motiver c'est des fois quand tu es
entre-deux les conditions climatiques
sont pas bonnes on a trop de travail
on va pas les on va y aller et du coup
on laisse passer les jours et les
semaines de courir ici vous êtes 100%
novices ne commence et évidemment pas
par un marathon essayez plutôt des
épreuves comme courir 10 km à elancourt
ou encore le grand prix des clés alors
c'est vrai on peut courir avec un vieux
shirt et des baskets usées
mais franchement c'est quand même mieux
d'avoir un équipement adapté pour
prendre un maximum de plaisir
les équipementiers proposent de plus en
plus de produits pour les amateurs de
running parfois très utile parfois
franchement gadgets pour faire un point
je suis allé à la rencontre d'alain
vidalies le patron de la franchise rando
running une entreprise saint-quentinoise
qui marche ou qui courent
à vous de voir après avoir été directeur
régional de go sport pendant 17 ans
alain vidal ce qui crée rando running à
guyancourt en 2009
il n'existait alors sur saint quentin en
yvelines aucun magasin spécialisé dans
l'univers de la course à pied fort de
son succès il lance une franchise en
2010 aujourd'hui rando ronning ce sont
14 magasins à travers toute la france
qui propose environ 250 produits la
franchise saint-quentinoise fonctionne
plutôt bien
d'ici la fin de l'année alain vidal ce
qu'ils espèrent qu'elle comptera entre
17 et 19 magasins
mais avant d'être un business man cette
inimitié surtout un pratiquant acharné
de course à pied pour démarrer ce qui
est très important aujourd'hui c'est
quand même d'avoir une bonne paire de
chaussures
il n'y a pas besoin de maîtres queux
après exorbitants aucune tâche au sommet
quand on démarre on est entre 90 et 100
euros
on a besoin d'une bonne chaussure avec
de l'amorti l'idée c'est vraiment de
faire évoluer votre équipement et votre
budget en fonction de votre niveau et de
vos objectifs
comptez par exemple une centaine d'euros
pour cette chaussure adaptée aux
débutants pour une pratique plus
intensive du running
privilégiez plutôt ce type de produits
on est sur une glycérine donc là on va
chercher beaucoup plus de confort
beaucoup plus d'un mortier a évidemment
sélection de fréquences aussi embauché
deux trois quatre entraînements dans la
semaine pour faire un marathon
ce sera plus adaptée par un jour de
course et côté textile alors plus
important c'est devant une bonne paire
de chaussettes et ensuite t-shirt
respirant surtout pas de coton antin
d'équipement mais voilà on sait que vous
fera mesure j'avais des produits ce type
là on est sur une première couche ok
vient la peau c'est un petit peu près du
corps mais c'est permet d'avoir chaud on
va jusqu'à quasiment zéro doré de dehors
ça respire ok donc le produit donc
s'évacue de très très belles
transpiration là encore en fonction de
votre pratique et de votre budget vous
pouvez ajouter une deuxième et une
troisième couche de vêtement
n'oubliez pas d'avoir un cuissard adapté
long mi longs ou courts et si vous avez
pour objectif de participer à une
épreuve intense où embarquent pour
complex un sac à dos un équipement
électronique et des compléments
alimentaires peuvent s'avérer utiles à
l'important à retenir c'est vraiment de
se renseigner auprès de professionnels
habitués à pratiquer la course à pied
selon alain vidal ski un équipement mal
adaptée peut avoir de fâcheuses
conséquences sur l'organisme
bon vous l'avez compris 50 en effet est
un territoire idéal pour pratiquer la
course à pied
pour connaître tous les événements en
lien avec cette discipline je vous
invite à vous connecter sur la page
facebook
est-ce qu y sport en ce qui me concerne
je vais rentrer pour me reposer et
préparer le prochain ce crime hague
on se retrouve très vite d'ici là portez
vous bien ciao bye